hello thank you to e for sponsoring this
video no it's not mark that is talking
live closer closer closer closer yes it
is me revenant I am here to tell you
that you can play with me if you just
click the link in the description below
I have a shining new abundant season 4
of Apex legends click the link click the
link click the link nothing bad will
happen if you do not click the link
nothing bad
nothing bad you have free will it is
your choice your choice your choice your
choice your choice nothing bad will
happen
click the link you're good at this game
we know the mechanics champions tomorrow
yeah well sound fundamentals are at the
heart of every good champion and we are
already champion so clearly we have
sound fundamentals and understand
everything that's happening can't fold
that the Spitfire I remember really
liking that good I'm still learning
these these oh yeah I see up there hi
male 8 don't worry oh oh [ __ ] God he got
me good right now they're both from the
ping area are they're in there yeah I'm
gonna try to zip line it out here
screw this well there's two of them on
me okay well we found him I escaped I'm
fine I'm like it's probably irrelevant
now oh you just broke their shield when
I say I got this here we go L star baby
L star baby L star it's apparently a
little bit my fault I'm gonna take the
blame on that L star baby I'm just
shocked I actually like managed to
grapple away appropriately because I
like my butt hairs skimmed that lava as
I was like trying to slide like I had
one helpfully was very fun very fun yeah
this imagine mark in a hail of bullets
is like you know Mario when he hits a
lava that's not a good mark gets the
period man
what a classic what a classic moment
glad I could provide that for you I get
so few opportunities to bust out my
Mario like I appreciate it I imagine I'm
gonna be just as good at revenant as I
am at Pathfinder you're pretty good at
Pathfinder so I can't wait to grapple
his revenant it's gonna be so fun if
you're as good at revenant as you are at
that Mario impression man good work Bob
and I can't believe I am jumpmaster
okay what's this guy's deal your cue
launches a little ball that missed like
an AoE thing that disables enemy's
abilities and does a little damage I
know there's still a white shield it's
it's big shield or nothing so piggy
probably careful outside Wade Oh yep
there's a box open right here I didn't
open I owe you nothing Bob I'm not
thanking you garbage boonies thank you
what does this guy just like - son today
or Sudan daddy I've got another point
where I say to sunder day just to make
people mad but no I I just do it
automatically I don't know what that is
so it doesn't make me mad it doesn't
matter okay it's been alluded to I'm
slightly upset we've got a lot of why
people who looted guys did you know
people looted here I heard that
somewhere have you heard that you heard
I'm gonna get I'm gonna go outside oh
hey there right there right there
I see range ain't gonna do [ __ ] to this
guy he closed the door don't one solo
duty hood don't let him do it to you all
right uh I'm gonna go out this side door
and rotate he's still coming in over
here mark yeah I'm that's why I'm
rotating okay I'm with you bum obviously
man just buildings bigger than I thought
it would be I thought that I would like
rotate oh god they were ready for me
what the hell that guy was ready it was
just busy killing one yeah they got
another team hitting them oh yeah roof
outside roof up roof up tippy tappy mark
are you come inside the door here you
know you're down there they're they're
trying to come Phyllis we need to I'm
gonna try to get mark up oh don't don't
don't do it now guy right there okay got
him nice there's more there's more
yeah right in my Robo heart I'm healing
guys being shot at I can't do much right
now I'm gonna try no that's not me there
no okay well I guess I'm doing this
god is good I'm an embarrassment just
want you guys to know that you know what
mark I believe in you oh thank you
we should move this way Andrea regroup a
little bit I think okay sounds good okay
we're outside of the Ring real real nice
like you up here moist the man help me
Mary I see them I miss them but I see
them and that's what's really matters I
see that mark I see
wait get him clip ah that's the that's
the problem stood there I was like what
are you gonna do about it
guys I look down the side saw their face
it was like man's bullets would be nice
you had to make your judgment call
you're like I'm looking you in the eye
all right you deserve this clap safety
first I gotta clean my gun out here
gotta hold your hand up and you gotta
tell him ten paces in Apex but it's like
so anyway I started reloading but I do I
think my flavor evidence as far as I
know I do like to send a lot I'll try to
do it I like setting a lot that was why
I was trying to say I like that going
I've only got at the one or two times
but I think it started maybe had to
scoop on me I probably said scoop on me
okay I haven't had a good chance to
shoot anyone with a sentinel the one
time I did I just missed like four shots
and then dud just banger I'm guessing
this is gonna connect it does not it
doesn't the tunnel this is the tunnel
that literally had nothing in it was the
complete opposite direction why I'm the
jump master trainer right there we need
go in the opposite direction
yeah what you talking about blue pillar
in front of us
get on there well I can't I can't do
that that's not fair
hey the circles I can't even climb a
rock okay I think the trains leaving as
I think we might have missed the Train
no no it's there I see it I see it it's
there it's there it's there it's there
it's there okay I've no no weapons of
any sort I'm ready
backpack here nope not that that was
mine don't look I didn't die didn't
knock dude I need that backpack for all
that oh there's two backpacks on this
boat and another gold knock down shield
you don't trained wait a minute hey you
got some good loot I wasn't I wasn't
done with you I hear like screeching and
banging you know
it's a thing down here down here I saw
somebody out here oh I lost you guys it
I'm sure why you well the gas affects me
too fun all right I'm gonna go down here
down there and going down
I broke the armor on the Mirage okay I
missed every shot there that's what you
want to see right
they closed the door let's yeah Bob I
would go huh come inside how did all of
that miss they're going out the far door
sure you use a Phoenix here but I guess
that works
I'm pushing around I don't know if
there's like a we're getting every life
okay - knocks I'm super low that's a
mirage ah he'll be coming that's
literally one in there gotta save me
there's like a jillion boxes here and
the towel they just finished having like
a three-way fight when we we walleston
on them God we're at hey we earned that
all skill baby oh yeah there is a bad
guy right there right right there yep
wait we're gonna want to get outside
here I think I know Wow damn it I'm
going around the outside wait
it's one one broken shield right here -
or knocked okay
just don't let him get like revives any
deal got him that's three not there's
this one has a gold shield oh another
one has a gold shield yeah but oh the
will kill the the thing
the ghost thingy I'm down on me ah yeah
that must have been the resurrection Oh
weird
okay I didn't know how that works no
neither I thought we got them fun yeah I
wonder if you can shoot the thing if you
see the like pyramid thing if you shoot
yeah yeah how close is the nearest
revive stage right outside the door you
know Mario oh wow yippee oh this is your
stuff I was about to take some of it man
it's kind of far we gotta go
now are we good this way my friends okay
through the tunnel of doom let's fire
okay there surely we don't have wreathed
oh no we don't have her this time ah you
guys got it you got it it's so fine it's
gonna tickle my bones no come come come
come come come come
I see the tickle fingers it's fine oh we
didn't holster to run faster yeah that's
one over there I'm shooting at moving
moving towards the people how did that
not hit alright how did that not hit one
thing I'm doing a thing I'm doing a
thing actually I really like that mark
I'm coming with you
oh yeah there's a thing to do how in the
world
now all three loads we should push what
you push down if we can yeah this SMG
ain't good at range turns out I'm not
good with sniping turn oh I just knocked
one come with me boys I just chucked it
grenade but I believe they're in there
should I drop my Z ability out here
should we touch it where we going I'm
already gone I'm going to the roof oh I
went almost over but I did not there in
there in there see him
careful whit got a little shield he's in
that building with you
looking around Safin was sneaking up I'm
healing careful okay going up
there's two gone God it's goddamn oh god
oh god
nice nice I can't oh god I'm trying to
self revive here I'm coming in
downstairs
oh wait push are behind you if you got a
grenade just chuck it upstairs if you
can I'm gonna finish her you now oh hey
Mark hello I'm here I'm the kill leader
get away oh man I remove Circle Circle
gonna move oh yeah follow wait
Oh shots waves are over there to 1000 I
hate it oh yeah no all right it's Austin
them mark if you can get down here I did
yeah I'm here okay
I'm healing up there right there right
there
that's you in the face nerd I'm real I'm
healing and then I'll be with you guys
okay I see him I see him I see him
careful mark yep yeah yep
they're low hello God they're lower my
all town on yep that's a good move i'ma
drop disease somewhere in the fog I just
don't know where
oh there's on the rock I see him I see
him mark touch their death protection
okay will do up on the top of the rocker
yeah he was up on the top of the rock
whoops I don't see what you can't heal
it that's not interesting I'm coming on
the right side we're done that box on
that box
yes bro keys down Shemp broke it on that
one right there oh [ __ ] I'm blind I
can't see where oh I respawn I think you
were killing it
yeah wait view I think you finished kill
later no if I don't much damage but I
sure stole the kills no no I think I
think you did quite handily that time
[Music]
[Applause]